Jesus
[Music]
in the world of anime there's nothing
quite like the thrill of a one hit KO
that moment when the tension is at its
highest and everything comes down to one
decisive blow So today we're counting
down the top 10 one-hit chaos in anime
history from the most epic to the most
unexpected these moments will leave you
breathless let's start the video
starting off our list with a banger we
have probably one of the most expected
scenes saitama vs Garo in one punch man
o met saitama by chance after he
destroyed some background Heroes but
garo's win streak ends there as he tries
to catch saitama by surprise he gets
completely knocked down the blink of an
eye this shocked everyone especially
Garo because who would have thought that
this bald guy in a kiosk knocked him out
in one move saitama has a lot of one-hit
chaos but this one just takes the spot
because well there's more to it than
meets the eye I don't want to spoil it
but be sure to stay tuned for this
series because you'll be surprised
[Music]
I know you remember this one if you're a
Black Clover fan in this battle our star
The Fearless protagonist of the series
takes on seke a known punching bag and
boy does he deliver
Escape
with no magical abilities to speak of
our start relies on his physical
strength speed and his trusty anti-magic
sword to take down his opponents and
take down seke he does with a Swift and
decisive blow that leaves the
overconfident Mage lying on the ground
defeated not only is this scene a
hilarious and satisfying moment for fans
but it also highlights our star's unique
and formidable fighting abilities it's a
great reminder that strength comes in
many forms and asked us lack of magic
doesn't hold him back in the slightest
while this scene doesn't have much
impact on the story overall it does set
the tone for our star's upcoming battles
and showcases the perfect balance of
action humor and character development
that Black Clover is known for
[Music]
next we have a battle of titans the
seven deadly sins escanor versus
derochio comes next on the list
this seed is a prime example of
escanor's Incredible strength he split
derochio in half with one swift blow
igniting his body from within as the
music comes to its climax the hype was
overflowing and it was satisfying to see
escanor stop all his attacks with just
one hand it was a true display of
strength and pride to see this fight
scene despite having excellent animation
and build up the characterization was
what really set it apart escanor's Pride
was both his virtue and his vice and it
was fascinating to observe how it
affected the battle
coming in riding a motorcycle on our
list is none other than Mikey versus
daiju from Tokyo Avengers
huh
Mikey arrives at the church in the
middle of Christmas night wearing
comfortable clothes and a happy smile
now if you don't know Mikey you wouldn't
expect what would happen next daiju
easily pummels Mikey to the floor with
his build difference dominating Mikey
but remember this guy is just 16 years
old he's built differently of course
this isn't a one-hit Chao for daiju
after celebrating his short win Victory
he's shocked to see Mikey casually
standing like there's no damage
whatsoever done to him anime Watchers
like us can't help but being excited as
we wait for Mikey to deliver his
counter-attack with a thud the scene
shifts to die July unconscious on the
floor it was a classic example of a
David vs Goliath fight this scene shows
Mikey's strength setting him apart from
other side characters and even the main
character
foreign
from the classic and iconic anime Dragon
Ball Z we have the battle between Vegeta
and frost foreign
Watchers are all waiting for that moment
where Frost will get his well-deserved
punishment from Vegeta with all the
atrocities he did join the entirety of
his time in the tournament now this is
somewhat of an anti-climactic fight but
not totally because we're talking about
Vegeta and we know how powerful he is
even the author can kill him but since
Dragon Ball fans have been waiting for
Vegeta vs Frost exchanging powerful
moves all they got is Vegeta one
punching Frost to sleep it's probably
one of the funniest anticlimactic
Knockouts in anime history and that's
the reason why this scene's on our list
[Music]
coming in next we have probably one of
the coldest moments in an anime that's
known for cold moments hakuro versus
Kyoya in that time I got reincarnated as
a slime
after remeru's kingdom was attacked both
of us and Them wanted some of that sweet
old revenge and we got it less of a
one-hit KO and more of a One-Shot kill
this scene cements itself as one of the
most satisfying jewels in all of anime
the music builds tension while the
animation does an amazing job at showing
us just how fast yoya is and how much
faster hakuro is when he took off yoya's
head looking at just how fast that
mocking expression turns into utter
despair is a sight to behold and
something that all of us won't easily
forget that only that this scene
establishes just how gritty and
action-packed the series will be
compared to the beginning episodes and
just how strong River's top for us
really is and trust me they'll get even
more overpowered just wait and see
[Music]
you
moving on now it's simple but satisfying
just a quick review on how strong sebas
is although he's not one of the floor
Guardians his power closely Rivals
theirs just imagine how strong that is
compared to some Cannon fodorous acid
the amalgamation of the animation and
music in this particular scene resulted
in its significant impact on watches
this scene accentuates the exceptional
combat skills and unwavering devotion of
sebast towards his only Master now eins
it also brings to light the immoral and
unethical nature of the noble faction
and the extremities that are willing to
undertake to maintain their homogeneity
because all it takes to take down
corruption is an old man in a butler
suit this one shot kill executed by
sambar's left us in a state of utter
shock and amazement the abruptness of
the attack and the savagery of the head
splitting left an imprint on The
Spectators cementing its place on our
list also the fact that Samos was able
to accomplish this feat while clad in
his Butler attire as to the overall
coolness of the scene because all
Butlers are great
and now we have a crazy knockout from an
even crazier anime kilua versus John S
from Hunter Hunter
foreign
asks Jonas how they should settle their
match and Jonas responds with murderous
intent as kilowatt mentions the loser
dies he ripped Jonas's heart out in an
instant ending this fight before he
could even make a move the shock Factor
was out of this world and not just for
Jonas but for everyone who witnessed the
scene kiduwa shows off his speed and
accuracy as he makes quick work of his
opponent this is evidence of his skill
and assassin training additionally the
Carefree manner in which he performs it
is almost amusing as John S begs for his
heart to return the scene was short
sweet to the point and it left everyone
standing in awe kilua's laid-back
attitude and moves probably make him one
of the best killers in anime and made
this scene worth it
up next we have Natsu versus Blue Note
in fairy tale
foreign
's top Mages previously he went
toe-to-toe with the formidable gildarts
Clive however his meeting with Natsu was
brief as the fire dragon slayer's magic
quickly scorched and vanquished him it's
tempting to believe that blue note was
nerfed to highlight Natsu's development
but the sheer intensity of Natsu's
Flames proves otherwise Natsu's fiery
Powers fully Unleashed and it was clear
that he wasn't holding back blue note
being roasted like the barbecue was a
spectacular sight making for an epic
moment I mean he did deserve it after
rocking those horrendous sideburns the
progression Nazi was made towards
becoming a powerful Mages evident in
this scene with his Fierce and fiery
magic he easily vanquished a top-tier
opponent watching how the fight was
actually conducted was entertaining
despite the fact that the outcome might
have seemed inevitable so if you enjoy
thrilling battles and amazing moments
you should definitely watch this fight
oh
prepare yourself if you're a one-piece
fan coming up next on our list is kaido
versus Luffy
[Music]
lay me
Luffy having a showdown of power against
one of the legendary yonko's kaido is
something everyone had been looking
forward to since the start of the series
we've all been anticipating Luffy
eventually fighting against powerful
enemies but you wouldn't expect kaido
and Luffy to meet and fight at this
point in the ark what's so impressive
about this scene is how it highlights
kaido's strength and power even the plot
armor for main characters can't save
Luffy from what hit him the animation is
superb with both kaido and Luffy being
drawn with Incredible detail to their
unique techniques visual effects the
impact of kaido's Thunder bongoa to
Luffy's face immerses us viewers in the
intensity of the moment and just how
much it hurt it leaves a lasting impact
on the audience and sets the stage for
Luffy's big white power up in the series
we see Luffy who's known for his
strength and resilience being completely
overpowered by kaido's one move it shows
that even the main characters have their
limits and it sets up a new challenge
for Luffy to overcome
[Music]
and that concludes our countdown of the
top 10 one-hit chaos in anime we hope
you enjoyed watching this video let us
know in the comments which one hit kale
is your favorite and as always stay
tuned for more anime content coming your
way thanks for watching